it's next big game week here on gamespot
and we're taking a class by class look
at evolve so you want to know what it
takes to play the assault a huge
swinging pair that's what of guns to
kill the horrible monster win what did
you think I meant as one of the three
assault characters hide focuses on
dealing damage dealing damage and
dealing more damage preferably in an
up-close-and-personal kind of way it
takes a special kind of crazy to want to
get all up in this squid demons face and
once you go there I mean really get in
there you'll never look at calamari the
same way again the aforementioned pair
of weapons are a minigun and a
flamethrower which pretty much makes you
a combination of every badass action
hero ever to grace the silver screen
when you're on the hunt it's best to
keep old flaming in your pocket and
brandish the minigun lil mini is
effective at longer ranges and as such
is almost always your first choice for
first engagement with your prey if you
start getting guff from the local
wildlife or spot an elite creature that
will give you and your fellow hunters a
helpful perk the generous bullets per
minute of the minigun should take care
of things nicely of course if the
critters get too close it's time to the
item up hides flamethrower deals a heap
ton of damage when your prey is in close
proximity which isn't terribly risky
when you're dealing with the local fauna
when you take on the big beasty however
things can get dicey it seems like the
very peak of madness to even stand your
ground against the monster so why would
you want to cozy up to a gargantuan
creature trying to kill you mmm because
you can light it on fire science tells
us that most animals retreat from fire
but can you really count on the sinister
human mind behind the monster to flee
speaking as a former Kraken who has been
set on fire during a match I can
confidently tell you that it is deeply
unsettling not to mention seriously
damaging the flamethrower doesn't just
give you an edge in the health bar
versus health bar
damaged game it gives you an edge in the
man versus monster mental game and
that's two good reasons why you are
going to spend a lot of time as public
enemy number one on the monsters list
fortunately you've got a personal shield
to help you withstand the monsters
direct aggression it renders you
temporarily invulnerable so when you pop
it don't just sit back if it's playing
coy and hassling you from a distance as
the Kraken loves to do Chuck you're
toxic grenades to flush it out of its
advantageous position these gassy clouds
are good for compounding damage like
when the monster is harpooned or for
keeping it away from downed allies
waiting to be revived that's about as
tactically complex as hide gets and if
you keep keeping on the damage you'll be
doing just fine still this particular
assault character has a unique
opportunity to mess with the monsters
mind get inside its head charge in like
a crazy flame spewing death-dealing
maniac and make that crack in question
who the real monster is